Today, we are going to talk about revenue
models. Very simply is, how does your
company make money. So in our last lectures
we talked about value proposition, customer
segments, distribution channels, customer
relationships; get, keeping and growing
customers. But today we’re going to be talking
about revenue streams. How is it that you make
money?
Now revenue models seems incredibly simple,
it answers the question, how does the company
make money from each customer segment.
But one of the things that we always tend to
confuse is the difference between a revenue
model and pricing. That is the amount of dollars
that we might actually charge for the product.
And this is a common mistake. What we’re
really trying to understand first is what value is
the customer paying for. And the first thing we
need to figure out is, what is our revenue model.
What’s the revenue stream. That’s our strategy.
But what follows is then pricing. What is our
tactics? So again, what we’re going to try to
figure out is what’s our strategy? Revenue
streams. And what’s our tactics? Pricing.
And together that means, how does a company
make money from each customer segment.